[Music]
what I've noticed when I watch the show
is that it almost seems like they're
trying to challenge you in some way
they're trying to put you in situations
that will perk you they put your
character in this outfit I think you
look fantastic
I would but when they come to you and
they say all right Jim yeah as Sheldon
is gonna be in a French maid's out yeah
you're obviously a good sport and a
terrific actor you go along with it and
you never said no have you ever said
that wasn't no that was a no that was
supposed to be that now didn't go over
very well no no I guess I'm just
grateful to have work but that no was
both that was supposed to be the
Princess Leia slave bikini they wanted
you to wear it at the slave bikini the
one that she's on Jabba the Hutt and yes
oh yeah I don't think we're dealing with
a Jabba the Hutt but we were dealing
with the bikini and I was like please I
would have needed three months with a
trainer to put on the Leia bikini you
know I don't consider myself extremely
vain are you mean to look at me I know I
should look better if I'm that vain but
I I just was like I can't wear that
right so you said not a scam yesyes
you said no to that and they were very
kind about it and they were nice they
said okay but you will do I say they
were very kind that was what well they
were come in you're a French base